alright hey everyone it's Mike Matassa
and welcome to the order flows market
analysis for Thursday September 28th
2017 the big news I guess is the
economic data look favorable there was a
small upgrade to the second quarter GDP
so it now stands at 3.1 percent that Dow
ended up 0.2 percent up for the day at
2022 381 there were some big moves today
most notably and in crude you had a nice
a nice move down and I'm going to talk
about crude in a second but first a
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision future strain
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading not only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results again the
tools gives in this presentation are the
order flows trader the order flows Delta
scalper and I'll talk about a bit about
the price rejector don't know why it's
not on there today but that's another
tool price rejecter looks for areas of
price rejection Delta scalper looks for
areas of changing supply and demand and
let's let's just jump into it I'll talk
about crude to begin with here give me a
second get the chart ok so crude this is
a bar chart ok but I want to show you
this move so you were on the same page
understand what I'm talking about the
move for me basically happened I mean I
don't know you have this swing high up
here at about 8:00 8:20 then yeah you
get this move from 50 to 40 all the way
down to 50 140 this move happened
basically around 10 a.m. but I'm you
know this is the Delta scalper Delta
scalper get it yeah I got the move but I
want go through some of the order flow
up in here to see if there's any sign
any sign in the order flow that you know
this move is gonna happen ok so that
that's gonna be what I'll be talking
about first so
taking it back here this is 8 821
Chicago time again you know he had just
been sort of you know coming up until
you know we I don't see we been going
sideways but since about 7 o'clock right
we're trading around 50 to 60 rotating
around 16 down to 45 back up the 60 then
821 you pop up here you have the price
rejecter right you got a bearish ratio
up in here also put a control up near
the top next bar you've got the Delta
scalper kicking in as well so you got
some signs here you got price rejection
up in this area you have the Delta
scalper as well so you know that you
just sort of come up here to the swing
high and you're getting hit in here with
the wave of selling now you did have the
Delta scalper here before but you don't
have the signs of price rejection you
don't have a bearish ratio you know this
these two bars here is actually kind of
similar to these in the sense that you
know you got the small Delta you've got
the Delta scalper coming in here you
know here you got a smallish Delta well
you don't have price rejection you got
the Delta scalper coming in here as well
even in the next the previous bar he
also had a negative Delta it looked like
possibly it could be turning in here but
you know as luck would have it it just
wasn't happening at this point yet
there's still a little bit of buying
left and you see how the market rallied
up over the next you know eight or nine
bars here we got up here now you're
seeing some definite signs of price
rejection and I said you didn't see a
price rejection here here you're seeing
then the bearish ratio 45 here you got
the price rejecter again you got a point
of control up near the top and again now
you got the Delta scalp or and you got a
bearish ratio in this bar as well you do
come back up you don't take out this
high though right in this next couple of
bars you get you get up close to it for
do you trade up to you trade up to this
point of control right here right this
is your swing high and what do you trade
up through your trade right up to it
right so again you know if you're saying
this is that high is that this is gonna
be your swing high now forget about the
move that happens later okay
really what I'm concentrating on is
trying to say you know decide if this is
going to be a swing high or not in if
the markets gonna sell off from here so
what's going to be a sign if this is
gonna be a swing high well
see we can't go higher than this high
but the key is the point of control
right are we going to trade up to that
area where you had this heavy volume
before it's almost about 2000 contracts
went through here earlier in this bar
and what do you do
boom you trade right up to it okay then
you start selling off are there any
signs okay watch the Delta obviously 750
negative 750 negative 7/25
that's bearish look at the bars what do
you see in this bar here yeah I put a
control up near the top that's bearish
you've got two imbalances you got
another two imbalances in this bar you
guys still got another two imbalances
okay now I'm a little convinced that
selling is starting to come in right
whereas here earlier you have like I
said you know these two bars here we're
kind of similar to the two bars later
except you know you're missing out on a
few things I say all you have here is
the Delta scalper or here you had signs
of price rejection in this bar and it's
821 bar you don't have it here but where
is the follow-through selling right you
see instead you see buying imbalances
you see aggressive buying here here here
you see green candles now you're seeing
the selling come in here all right yeah
but I mean I know some people say well
you got some buying imbalances here yeah
okay but this is my resistance level
right here at 72 and what do you do you
trade up to 72 then the selling comes in
right that's what resistance is there
for right it's there to tell you that
that's where you should be looking for
some selling to start creeping in back
into the market if you're trading back
up here look for selling to come in if
this is going to be your high if this is
going to be resistance and it is and
then you start trading down here you get
a nice deck selling a balance okay so
you know it's starting to shape up the
way you you know the way you want it to
write a bunch of imbalances next bar
imbalances next bar imbalances negative
all negative deltas I mean you're
getting a couple bars here and there
with positive Delta 358 okay just
because you got one bar is positive
Delta doesn't mean the move is over but
not by any means I mean don't get don't
fall into this trap that you think you
know this because you got the positive
Delta the move is over you know I mean I
think one of the reasons why traders
fall for that trap is because they're so
used to looking for divergences right
and you know one of the keys to
divergence in the deltas heaven you know
having a positive Delta after at the end
of a move so don't fall for that trap
don't fall for just because you got one
bar with positive Delta that the move is
over I mean if anything you know maybe
you can lighten up your position but
just because you got one bar with
positive Delta does not mean the move is
over and what happens it's just you know
it starts it hits this area you got the
positive Delta here and you got negative
making a small positive as well negative
so you know there's still selling in
here right it's just sort of wandering
around it's not really going anywhere
again it's just it's not going anywhere
not going anywhere not going anywhere
now this now it's ten o'clock right so
you got this one bar here very strong
positive Delta you got one thirty nine
three three four ten seventeen this is
actually what the Delta surge would look
like I don't have the Delta surge
indicator on this on this chart but that
is a delta surge and what you're gonna
look for obviously is you're going to
look for continuation you're gonna look
for buying to continue and what happens
selling comes in negative Delta negative
Delta small Delta fifty one that's kind
of a neutral number and obviously 887 so
you forget you can forget about this
this Delta search you know that the
buying coming in it's over it's over
already okay so don't be sitting here
you know oh I'm wrong from you know 40
or whatever and it's trading down here
you know when you see this bar with it
negative Delta 887
if you're in that position you got to
get out there's there's no reason to
stay in that position and more selling
comes in - a thousand Delta you know
again one bar small positive Delta one
eighty nine but then it comes right back
with - 264 - nine 67 and then the bottom
just drops out here boom boom boom come
down into the new lows no divergences
down here you do have the Delta I sorry
the price rejector at this low I mean
we're looking at this low thinking maybe
we can bounce I mean you got a couple
things that kind of like I didn't like
that you still had negative Delta on
both of these bars here cuz you know if
I'm gonna be looking for this market to
move up I'm gonna need some buying come
in and you know where's that going to
show up
it's gonna show up in the Delta right
and it's not showing up here we got this
one borrow 600 Delta up and it comes
right back with negative Delta negative
Delta then that's is not shaping up as a
market that's ready to start rallying
right I'd want to see 600 don't feel
like you got here then you know another
positive Delta here and here not
negative negative
and what happens boom it starts coming
down into new lows
now you got a divergence here with the
ratio the next bar you do have us
imbalance down here this you know I see
imbalances like this at the bottom
little green bars to me that's a nice
little short-term signal you know go and
get long and you do get a little bit you
did get a little bit of a bounce I said
you got your ratio and divergence which
is a go-to trade for me you know it went
up not much it went up about 8 cents and
it just came down into new lows you know
that that one didn't work out I'm not
gonna say it by any means that I'm not
yeah I can't talk my way out of it
because you know it's just a failed
trade yeah you got stack multiple
imbalances here not a stacked imbalance
like here yet
three imbalances okay that's a bullish
sign but it comes right back here with
you know three imbalances going in the
opposite direction and boom we should
just start selling off into new lows
you've got so you had those divergences
that failed right this one then when you
get down here at 10:58 you get another
divergence and other divergence then
they fail again you know once I start
seeing some divergences failing in a
short period of time you know to me
that's that's a sign of this market can
can go you know can keep trending so you
know by this time when you get down to
48 right this low here it's me that's a
safe sell but you know again you know
when you're trying to trade breakouts
right because you're making a new low
that's gonna be a breakout sometimes the
capacity the trade can be a winner right
you can break out by two ticks and
technically yeah it broke out but you
know from a training standpoint how much
profit do you wanna get out of their
trade you know that's going to determine
whether the trade was a successful or a
loser just say no that yeah it did break
out but if it breaks out by two ticks
that's not going to be a very successful
trade so you know you want to
a strong break out and you get a decent
break out you know from 48 it gets down
to 31 actually gets down below it down
in here I'm gonna talk about this in a
second but you know this to me this is a
decent train to take it does break out
after these failed divergences you know
so again you know from the 48 level it
trades down to the 22 but you know for
me that I'd be happy to get you know 15
ticks out of that trade which it did
afford it did give it to you now you get
down here right now here you got the
price rejecter again I do I don't like
that you have the negative Delta on it
but you know I could live with that
because I know that there is some
support down here I know the first time
you hit this low you also got negative
Delta I see the volume it's quite strong
alright it's quite strong on the mid
side and when I say I could accept this
negative Delta why it's because I know
there was aggressive buying coming in
late because this market this bar
finished pretty quick is bar took two
minutes and then the next bar you got
some buying imbalances you got a stacked
imbalance didn't work out it just it
came up and went a little bit higher
than some selling came in and he came
down in here you got this bullish ratio
okay so you sold off so you know again
this buying imbalance the stack buying
and balance didn't necessarily work but
we're still holding this price rejecter
level down here at the low and what do
you got you got some price support
coming in here with the bullish ratio
here and now you got again a nice
positive Delta okay but one again you
know one nice big positive Delta isn't
going to be enough right I want to see
in the next bar again a nice positive
Delta 500 and you got it okay so now
we're starting you know we finally
strung together two nice strong Delta
numbers nine sixteen five five eight you
know here you got six 38k that's good
that's a start but you need another one
you don't get it here you got negative
negative Delta here you got positive
Delta
I'm at the bar sold off that's not a
good sign because it's telling you price
action late in the bar is negative
because we're still selling off you come
down here negative Delta negative Delta
but then again you got the bullish ratio
the stopping volume here the ratio well
is a low and then with a positive Delta
and X bar positive Delta so now that's
two
okay that's a good sign that this market
can probably get a move higher and a
nice bar here nice positive Delta 792
and then you come up in here you know
and you do go higher a little bit in
this next bar before you get the price
sorry the Delta scalper here with the
bearish ratio bearish ratio
you just kind of go sideways again you
know you do have a negative sign in here
at this point you know it's like yeah
you know can this market go isn't going
up and is it going down I don't know at
this point you know if you're staring at
this you know in real time you're
sitting there you're kind of mixed it
kind of mixed again I'm not necessarily
a big fan of taking signals like Delta
scalper going into lows again
but I mean we've been under pressure we
just had a move you know from we're
trading a buck lower than we were three
hours ago
so you know we can't we move another
dollar lower of course we can but you
know the chances of that happening you
know not great that nicely they say
we're down here at this low I'm more
looking for reasons to be buy and be a
buyer than a seller you know so you know
trying to pick this trying to say that
you know pick this low and find a buying
places it's kind of difficult
you know because you started to rally
but then you got the bearish sign again
and eventually what happens is you just
sort of go sideways
unfortunately so you know were there
signs I mean again you know I spend a
bit of time talking about trying to look
for a buying opportunity off this low
and it was but it's kind of short-lived
but you know hopefully you could have
seen something in that order flow
earlier when you were trading up in here
you know the signs were here that you
know you got price rejection nothing
scalper you got this decked imbalance
and you got all that negative Delta
building up in here and you know to me
that that's where you want to see it
right you want to see this sort of
structure you know higher up in the day
then you know near the low of the day
know again you know before you get too
excited with you know with the Delta
scalper like I just showed you the
one-minute chart but you know just
really quick how does it look on some of
these other charts no the Union Renko
chart this is it for the day you had one
signal right up here 52
what is that about 50 to 55 right before
the big sell-off me did rally back up to
close to 70 before it got the sell and
you got a buy signal down here so I mean
this one looks nice you know I don't
know sort of risk you're using on this
trade I mean but if you just had to stop
right behind this club when you got
stopped out in a mess the entire move
what can you know but hopefully you're
getting you know you give it some space
but now again you know yeah again you
know fool this guy I want you guys to
see this stuff I'm going to show you the
987 tick chart cuz it it didn't look so
hot on the 1987 tick chart honestly but
again you know I'll show it to you
because I don't want that one person
trading in 1987 tick chart to be misled
where is it here cuz you know there's a
trending market and sometimes on
trending markets you go buy signals and
you know on this move down you just got
a bunch of buy signals as catching a
falling knife and just get
chop-chop-chop-chop but that's why you
got to have you know tight stops you
know every time you try to pick I'll say
pick a low but pick up a turning point
it kind of you know you can stop talking
stop talking stopped out you did catch
this move late in the day but again this
isn't much of a move it's about 30 cent
move but again you know that's a 987
tick chart you know but if you were to
say break it down to a I haven't looked
at the 233 tick chart but I'm gonna pull
it up here if I could find it and just
you know just compare it Alex I want to
see how this stuff works on you know
different different types of charts okay
so how does it look here okay well let's
go back to the move that was around 9:00
this morning
so you know it was catching some of
these nice little swings here you take
this out you know you're getting a move
here getting a move here get a move back
up there you know move up there and move
down here and move up move back down you
know some moves up here you know you
hopefully could have caught in the
majority of this move here this was the
big move down from you know 40 down to
this is down to about 15 or 14 you know
by signal then cell signals kick in
again this by failed this by failed you
know the cell worked out this one and I
don't know this one worked out you got
fail reverse that one you know some of
these worked somebody's you know you got
some small stop outs here probably you
know hopefully could have caught you
know something like this from 26 up to
you know 44 so you know there were moves
to be had in that in the crude oil today
alright so this is the euro currency and
again you know people always say oh I'm
like you're always trying to pick highs
and pick clothes well I'm not I'm still
in the order flow tell me you know that
there's a selling opportunity or there's
a buying opportunity near a low or a
buying or selling opportunity near a
high and there's a perfect example okay
the euro currency is the euro currency
now about 8:20 in the morning we started
trading up near our highs okay
and I just want to show you is there any
reason for me to be selling up at these
highs no you know you hit this high here
there's no reason to be selling this
high to this high or this high you got
some small Delta's six seven you know
minus one but still nothing really other
you know in the order flow is he still
got all positive Delta's up in here he's
still you know you got these bullish
bars here bullish ratios you know as
you're coming back up into the highs you
got for the most part you got buying
imbalances there's there's no reason
yeah I mean even here you got you know
236 28 so small Delta's 102 507 now you
get up in here you know you got a
negative Delta of minus 127 okay just
it's got negative Delta when
one bar doesn't necessarily mean the
move is over yeah you got if you're
gonna move off from a high you're gonna
need more than one bar with negative
Delta you're gonna start need to string
it together okay now you say here you
got your divergence so you got your
negative Delta you got your you know
your your bar starting to turn down
you got a new high so you got one bar
two bars three bars with negative Delta
okay you know that to me though it's
it's probably still not enough you know
here you got a small Delta of eight okay
okay I'm still not convinced still not
convinced 83 you know case it's bar
turned down okay that's good negative
Delta of 190 but the bar is green so
it's telling me maybe there's still some
support in here and you see the volume
347 103 155 so to me this is actually
really got the negative Delta I find
this bar a bit supportive of the market
looks bar you go up a little bit turn
down you got the negative Delta small
though negative 29 so there's still not
any solid you know things screaming at
me saying hey get short yet but you know
you just gotta watch it you know
sometimes it shows up right around the
high now you know we're seeing we're
gonna show up now here you got negative
Delta's okay so let's just step back
here so presents nine ten to nine twenty
multiple bars with some small positive
Delta okay but overall negative okay
still negative but it's a green bar you
know some support of buying 342 168 81
I'm gonna 113 so there is some
supportive volume in there but still
then negative Delta negative Delta okay
you know if if at this point you know
it's knit this one's not clear signal
yet to get short but you know it's one
of those things you know you put a gun
to my head pick a position long or short
I definitely want to be short you know
and then it starts and then it starts
selling off okay and I'm not going to be
surprised that at one point you're gonna
see you know a bar with a big strong
negative Delta and you get it in here -
290 so you know again you know you're
hanging around in here right the high
was here in this bar and you know you're
you're over here just you know this is
what a market that looks like
it's gonna sell off looks like you know
you're just hanging around the high
mostly negative deltas you know
imbalances you know not necessary this
case don't really have that many I mean
you have a couple buying imbalance one
here and one here but you know and then
you got some selling imbalances but yeah
other than the Delta right it again it's
one of those things you know if you had
to choose a position on which way you
want to go you know to me it looks and I
failed it right down a scale of one to
ten I'd call this about a six point five
that looks it looks bearish you know
it's not as clear as as you'd like it
but overall looking at these Delta's it
does look bearish finally you get the
move you know again from what is that
the forty six area forty five area and
then it starts moving down into the 30s
and just sort of hangs around below
forty but then again you know yes it's
not pulling away right even though it
got down to thirty it's just going
sideways again it's not you know rallies
back up at the forty back down into the
30s back and forth but still look at
this all still negative Delta's in here
and then get up deltas eventually it
does get this push lower down into the
mid 20s before you get the Delta scalper
kicking in here with a nice little
buying signal and the market goes up a
bit but again it's it's one of those
things sometimes it's it's more clearer
and you know that the you know the
negative signs in the market when you're
at this high are there in this case you
know this is like a stretched-out signal
to get short but and definitely not to
you know if you're a long still cut your
lungs get out of them but again you know
on this move up there was no notion no
signs to be looking to get out of this
position it's not they get up here and
you start stringing together these
negative Delta's that's when you know
that's that's when it's changing right
it's not like you got to hold your
position
you know until infinity no you know when
you start reading the order flow and the
Delta and now it's telling you okay
you just had this period of you know
buying you know all these positive
Delta's now you come into this area
you're up here at your high and you got
predominantly negative deltas what does
that tell you well it tells you the
market is getting primed to move lower
which it does okay so y'all in this
presentation for today this week this
weekend I promise I'm gonna get you guys
a bunch to stop I got it I'm gonna do a
presentation on means in general cuz I
got a lot of interest from people I
sound like I'm gonna be a broker um
giving out this information but it's
good information because people ask you
know eh what other markets can I look at
and you know sometimes for people that
are new to order flow yeah it's easier
sometimes to trade other markets Basalt
besides minis and crude oil so you know
I've got a few things planned to do over
this weekend I fingers crossed I could
get to them and you know I want to do
some more explanatory videos on some
other stuff for you guys also it's just
a little bit hard with my voice right
now but hopefully I'll get those out for
you this weekend or sooner
alright everyone so thanks and have a
great day bye bye